[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it didn't even play hi hello what
happened okay
so fun fact it's weird I want my
playstation because that's where I
normally play during the day this is a
FX live apex legends live stream for
octane however I get this notification
that it says it starts at 12 for the
season pass which is mildly confusing
and makes me worried because everything
I knew was that it was supposed to come
out of 10 so let's try restarting my ps4
and see what's up
if not I'm gonna try PC 2 and hope the
reason why it was on that like screen
just now was because it was uh it was me
not wanting to be in the game until 10
because everything I knew was that this
game was supposed to or the season pass
was supposed to be at 10 a.m.
however I'm gonna just got bamboozled as
Ethan just said because if you looked at
that notification I showed you in the
Google the PlayStation Store
it says 12:00 p.m. in which case I got
jebaited and that sucks I know they said
10 a.m. Pacific but if you look at that
one screen I just showed you that
PlayStation itself says 12 but we're
gonna find out I could totally be wrong
I just got back in row you're gonna show
octane yet or what I'd love to show
octane yes PC know ps4 ok that's ok
guess what fun fact I have both I have
accounts on both so let's hold on you
one second I will I will I will fix this
alright I'm gonna try PC
[Music]
one second we need octane I know I love
me some octane I've been bamboozled it's
ready on X block X cone give it to you
oh wait hold on
we use the same HDMI and Ethernet for
both so it was still stuck in my
playstation however we're gonna check PC
go find out PC is DL right now okay
no one care show the character well you
know anyone that cares for ps4 should
care
faster okay faster
okay my apex can be updated on PC so
there's that stop talking okay well then
if I stop talking you got nothing then
right yeah a Playstation for me said 12
p.m. which is in two hours from now
for whatever reason whereas pci at least
have an update ps4 update is out now
people are saying it's out is octane
free no he's not
you need the credits or buy it with
coins I just got an update on ps4 okay
well let me finish doing this update cuz
it's almost done
then I'm gonna check on ps4 sounds good
I apologize for everyone's anchor I
guess I could show you that it's
updating but then it's not gonna matter
so just give it a second
I apologize maybe I should have just
left you guys hanging on a live screen
but ps4 is updating okay cool thank you
so much appreciate it I'm gonna let this
PC one finish just in case we need to go
back to PC it's got four seconds so
might as well someone said no update on
PC or ps4 sorry I'm gonna check hold on
if your ps4 is not updating I would say
you should definitely restart your ps4
that's the best way are you playing solo
yeah that's the problem someone else
might pick him pick them yeah I was
trying to join it with squad mates in
the office but they're busy because
there's kind of like GDC is going on and
then there's also a Google event that's
also going on this updates finalizing
here so hold on
I actually have to set up so hold on
I can still check the other thingy PCs
finalising so give me one second I'm
gonna try to see a ps4 works cuz I know
people are curious so okay according to
my ps4 there's no update right now
but I'm going to restart my ps4 they've
been boozled you I still have no update
yeah because a legend if you read the
apex post on ps4 it says 12 p.m. for
them alright so what I'm gonna do is
we'll just go to PC what should it go to
PC the thing that sucks is I don't have
like coins or that maker I actually have
credits on that but alright so we're
going to a PC I'm gonna play with the
controller though because that's what I
do I'm a controller guy
never mind ps4 up data I don't believe
it we'll see I'll see because I just
restarted my ps4 so I'll believe it when
I see is it myself instead of continuing
to read chat spew to me that it's out in
the meantime let me try to multitask and
do two things at one time
season one PC you can see it there like
I said yeah ps4 is not out if you look
at the ps4 notifications you can see
jump into season one where is it
oops into the wild I'm gonna show it to
you guys just so you guys don't think
I'm lying to you guys because it says if
you look at that one it says Tuesday
March 19th 12 p.m. for ps4 so I don't
know why it's later but we're gonna jump
into some apex some high-octane gameplay
everyone saying you happiest were live
well according to my stuff it doesn't
show that so I don't I don't believe it
I'm gonna show you this one see see oh
my game just crashed I think or did it
yeah my game on PC just crashed sick up
no can come back our oh it's got a
different background look at this it's
got a slightly different background into
the wilds alright let's go bye
let's go by octane our boy here who as
Diablo hold on we gotta unlock them use
my creds my fat creds
I have not bought caustic or Marah Oh
what's this battle pass oh shoot I gotta
buy the battle pass - Oh what do we got
we got some skins I also got a hold on
once I go
all right so you get a free apex packet
- got some gun skins open got some some
voice lines
that's this little old BP boost thing
[Music]
all right yes I don't know what's up
with the ps4 one but according to the
thing it says 12 for ps4 so we could
switch back we want alright
unlock the legendary I don't have any
coins - but we'll check the skins out
there Zell he kind of looks like an Oni
actually more like a demon
not so much El Diablo speed demon okay
so Sam he's got hair
did he always have here in the original
no he's got a little hat okay got a
victory lap he looks like a dirt dirt
racer and then same thing with that one
and then I'll guess these are all the
kind of the same wait didn't I just
unlocking oh no these are skins okay
that's why all right let's go let's go
let's just play oh I need to buy the
season pass though hold on I should've
thought this through one second oh you
can either oh that hold on I got I
should show this you either buy the
battle PLAs that comes with three
exclusive skins or you buy the battle
pass bundle that gives you the three
skins and 25 valve I don't know we're
not we're buying the the normal one one
second I gotta buy this off screen
though for obvious reasons
y'all charge by 2000 coins
no no no no we're not we're not we're
not succumbing to that that life mainly
because I mostly buy it stuff on ps4 oh
man I gotta put credit card info in are
there any skins for others ooh that's a
good question I don't know yet hold on I
got a I got to buy this real quick it's
available for ps4 now not even kidding
yeah well I don't know it's not for me
[Music]
[Music]
mate just go on your ps4 man all right
okay I will literally do that one more
time and just show it to you guys just
so you guys can see that my ps4 because
you wanted you bait me so hard oh just
kidding now it's now it's downloading
there it is alright ps4 is up - all
right you didn't you bait me Thank You
chat
I just bought a thousand coins on PC
though and I'm about to have to buy a
thousand coins on ps4 - great awesome
here we'll play we'll play on PC until
we get ps4 back Jesus Christ we're
probably not even gonna get him but
whatever all right we got three skins oh
you want me to check other skins right
so now we have a new rate skin survivor
it's got the little thing it's I don't
know she's like horizon zero dawn - you
got one for mirage that I didn't buy
have a character for so whatever oops
and there is lifelines in the menus it
doesn't look like there's more skins
outside of the ones I just got so
whatever we'll see sorry for not
believing you in chat I just I've been
debated too many times it's downloading
on my ps4 so once that finishes I will I
will get back to that one just because I
probably have a higher success rate
there obviously and if any of these go
down we can go we can hot swap back and
forth to try to get octane games in I
just need to buy the coins though for
thingy
sorry if I'm trying to do two things at
one time and I'm also sorry that I'm
semi neglecting you chat right now but
please be patient with me no don't do it
he's mine
I showed the octane skin scrub back if
you want to
I will play like one gosh darnit octane
what's up crime how you doing
I see you man give me give me that
octane bro come on you gotta be first if
you don't get first you don't get octane
I could see if any of my buddies are on
I don't worry don't worry
to get octane we will just play spicy
games there will all be spicy so spicy
I'm going to the ship I don't care I
want octane yeah Ethan mentioned if you
leveled up and then by like caustic or
Mirage you can definitely afford octane
which is why I could afford octane I'm
so good
cuz I selling everyone
there's on behind the jail stick kill me
octane Oh a stim kill me please thank
you all right did they add solo not that
I noticed
okay I'm trying to do two different
button presses at one time okay let's
try again try again
we'll try to get octane again actually
one second no one online okay
did this finish 70 seconds left on ps4
ps4 update is 3.08 one gigs but there's
going to be an octane everywhere yeah
for sure okay you can't afford them you
guys can't afford octane you can't
afford them no yes
get off of him
where's your birthday present not here
apparently the match summary looks cool
Oh is it different
I'd even notice I just bypassed how much
of the battle past nine fifty be quick
dude I can't be quick I can't be quicker
if I don't have first pick someone asked
for Octane's ability okay so he has stim
pack which you know you take some help
to then run faster which is very like
titanfall ish you have a passive which
gives you HP back oh I should just bring
up the things for you guys next time
I'll just bring up his abilities next
game quit linemen around the good news
is if I really wanted to on for ps4 I
can pick off I can get an octane skin
but I just don't know if I'm gonna like
the character but he has a small hitbox
so probably thank you a Chevalier I said
your name right oh boy a gun leg oh hi
that was a knock to Octane's
a cool Phoenix get purple armor all
right we got one man let's go let's go
squabble
oh it's lagging there are some I'm dead
oh we got one though at least alright
that's fine
that's why we got it we got two kills
there die until play knocked in yeah
pretty much
uh I think PS we're finished for me
alright we're gonna we're just gonna
have to do two loads at one time oh here
battle past points a twenty four
lifeline legend bonus to 40 lifeline
first kill of day okay so alright
there's your rewards from the next one
so they did add some stuff their PCs are
full of hackers I actually haven't ran
into too many hackers and then it starts
to make you think like did I actually
fight a hacker yeah I know it's
interesting for sure octane is not part
of the battle paths that is correct
you have to buy him separately but I
feel like if you played a bunch you
probably could afford it oh no please
please be higher than mechanical rat
he's got him queued up no give me octane
oh shoot I think like PS board now has
like some weird stuff going on because
um or the the apex just in general the
loading is like kind of wonky because
like it froze for me on PC for a second
and now it's freezing on ps4 how much is
the battle past 9:50
what's up bouncy jelly gaming ICU oh
he'll jump yeah yep that's the one thing
about like switching characters a lot is
like you just kind of forget your your
abilities what role do you play the most
it's interesting um I think that uh that
I play lifeline if no one plays lifeline
and then I play either bloodhound Wraith
bangle or Mirage pretty much I also
didn't say tray I also didn't say
anything about flaming losses on hackers
I actually haven't really ran into a
KERS to be honest on a personal level I
don't know why this is not working for
PlayStation close the app and then open
it again it was stuck trying to load I
should break off to you
if there's a bad guy there bad guys
everywhere actually so he's got like was
that like a kind of like Irish Scottish
I'm thirsty I don't care this is dumb
you never want to oh he just left he's
like I didn't get thing either he's like
I didn't get octane either I'm out of
here
fine even though you stole octane from
me I'll be a good teammate times over
why are we not you go honey it's a
runway animation is kind of funny
it's the right the Thunder going
you can't game over a trip in advance
okay hey echo garage chess Oh revived at
the far one that's a bar 1f it oh yeah
hell yeah let's go now fat it damn he
gets his all really fast I guess it
makes sense because it's not like a like
a crazy one but get stuck oh no his
Spitfire or peacekeeper Oh
mistakes are made mistakes we've got the
season wins thing uh mistakes were made
but it's ok we does a decent game sorry
I'm trying to like do two things at once
race first kill of the day let's go
we're just gonna cycle through all the
characters until thing I'll turn it up
sorry octane is lit that was too much
I'm so sorry headphone users users okay
I think I got into PlayStation maybe
it's spinning oh come on
raging snapper you can't afford it you
ain't got the octane yeah you don't have
octane
there's his ability Swift mend move 30%
faster than second it's show time each
choice changes everything all right we
got the battle pass on his floor too
unlock him
don't worry I'm a multitasker fine
[Music]
okay we have octane now huh what
why already
is that a new hot spot or something I've
never gone there on first drop stay
focused you got it I'm gonna switch the
ps4 after this though how the F D by
valve has 950 coins
oh I like the sound of a pile eggs maker
we should test out his uh his stem huh
so let's steam it up I'll just stay in
your way
alright let's see how long the passive
takes the passive is pretty slow it's
pretty slow actually like look at how
long it's taking to get the HP back so
it doesn't really counteract the stim
that quickly so I'm curious to see how
that plays out in the future
I need higher bitrate you think so it's
like at 9k Victor it's kind of I don't
know or 9k total if you count audio I
guess we could try 10k tomorrow in the
future new guy has the stim ability
which is from titanfall you sacrifice
some health to gain speed boost and then
he also has the passive which you just
gain health back slowly
oh god prowler
all right and then he's got the bounce
pad which is his alts stop hey he's up
top
it's nice to look fire I like it fifthly
hanging a dude in a terrible fire he
steamed it Eddie Eva got shrekt by good
job team I did nothing was he worth
buying rubber Mirage I don't know I
haven't played much of him yet
oh come on ray raging snapper I think
Grady was never is dead if we die here
we're just gonna switch you could give
oh you're dead unless he jumped off me
can I kill myself coq10 cost 950 gold or
credit 4,500 guys buy octane rod you can
see predictable say so you see is
passive slowly working
the Rings closing in a minute we're not
close pick up a heavy glass wingmen over
here you have any meds 25 seconds rings
far ring was far don't worry guys I'm a
bounce pad we gotta go down like this
way man be sick if you could drop like
more than one you do one than another
one can gain swap by a octane for me I
know sorry use the pad off the ship
oh I did we think alike : Sanders can
you show the battle past when the game's
over yes I'm gonna switch over the ps4
to so you can see it from there I think
I think I should be stimming more he
makes a little gun to hand like I got
used to using the stems with in-game
credits as you can 12500 you just like
Mirage and caustic I think it's 1500 if
it's not twelve thousand five hundred
four thousand the other trio one
portals ready he says all right let's
skip to it
Wow you can spam this thing holy smokes
oh can you do it twice oh no I can't
okay
the ability looked like it wasn't grayed
out so I was like I'm gonna do it again
it's a like two second ish cooldown can
you play with your shirt off no that
would be breaking Terms of Service can
you shoot while stim is active yeah I
believe so can you use his abilities I
just used like two of them and his
passive is just get health back slowly
over time so I will continue to try to
use them to the best of my ability
wait took the hollow okay
who should I get caustic or octane oh
what's up a deep eye eye on a personal
level because I've been playing so much
I would rather take octane but that's
that's just me
you guys didn't hear that right
we're high octane all the time but I was
poorly played
all right that's Mike that's on me all
right um real quick I'm gonna show the
battle pass then I'm gonna switch the
feed to ps4 so let me show that real
quick here's the battle pass you get the
three skins right off the bat level two
you get a triple take skin and apex pack
as you continue to go higher and higher
you get more get more skins you get an
epic apex pack so you get a chance for a
higher twenty six
I'm just trying to look at the higher
tier stuff what's this get a octane skin
you get a thrill of the hunt Prowler 51
these are just boost right okay and at
oh look at the silver storm so that's a
havoc skin right and then another havoc
skin that's pretty cool silver storm and
golden idol all right one sec we got a
soft appeal or real quick
alright American maniac that's not very
nice of you please keep it clean if
you're not gonna keep it clean I would
just get rid of you I think that octane
is a Hispanic or all right oh did you
guys want me to get a skin I'm willing
to do it for the chat well okay here
I'll buy a legendary skin for chat what
do you guys want what do you guys want
I'll use my hard-earned credits or yeah
crafting part sorry which which would
you like I don't really like El Diablo
and that's just like samurai I don't
know I don't I don't think his are that
great there okay guys well you guys
think I'll buy a skin though I'm willing
to buy an octane skin you guys think
this one's better the victory lap or
gold rush one or the El Diablo
he's like samurai cyberpunk here battle
past is 950 El Diablo looks sick do you
like it more than the trials looking guy
so El Diablo yeah zerk gets out the
biker motocross skin motocross won the
gold one samurais suit suits you that's
true el Diablo who there's a lot of
people I can only buy one I'm only gonna
buy one so either Gold Rush I think it's
gold rush or El Diablo
I don't think I like victory lap I like
the gold and I don't really like speed
demon so it's definitely gonna be El
Diablo or Gold Rush a lot of gold rush
lot El Diablo man this is tough this is
tough
el Diablo generic yeah this one this
one's got he I don't know he's got a
helmet but his biker El Diablo El Diablo
the one after Diablo so you like speed
demon the one where he has hair I think
he looks gross here oh can you show the
finishers yeah yeah that's a good point
so he puts a balance pad on you I think
or no it's a grenade okay and then you
got full throttle
okay um gold rush gold rush gold gold
gold gold gold
alright everyone saying mostly saying
gold all right we're gonna go gold gold
rush here for the meme dreams
alright no one's on let's go yeah sorry
I think I saw more gold so I'm gonna go
gold do a strawpoll that's true I
should've did a strawpoll that took that
would take a second though a lot of gold
rush I went gold rush show this games
please I basically showed you the skins
bikers don't suit on the battlefield
why not what's his ultimate he drops
down a bouncy pad so if you were playing
Friday they were bouncy pads in market
so wanna be junk rat he's got two
prosthetic legs gold rush up to you
thanks pony
that's very kind of you oh come on they
are once for one thing yuuki-kun results
oh cool cool cool cool
we got octane we got octane baby we got
high octane gameplay here is it only one
legend for season I don't know right
let's go for a ride dude look at my sick
trials fusion player here
el Diablo had--we've power that's true I
you know what I didn't factor that in I
could have went for the weave dreams
introducing can you shoot and fight
while using octane speed power yes you
can't say I'm the stunt man funny that I
just picked this done man
no the biker I picked the biker toy can
you buy battle passion games yes but you
need to have like coins though so you
can probably earn enough coins for the
next one but right now if you want
season one battle pass you can have to
spend $10 off
I hope I have some skill I don't know
I've been playing a lot of this other
game and this is throwing me off and I
can't talk about other game yet but
we're probably gonna stream it tomorrow
oh god for the night user I hate the
mute oh this is the hot zone I didn't
even know wow that guy's got out I
wonder if he can die from skin I should
test actually
I think I could die from stem over stim
okay I keep trying to stem sorry team
hates for doing science here octane is a
junkie oh hell yeah he's a junkie Ivan
I've literally had him stim like three
or four times okay you can't kill
yourself with Sam I need I need heals
okay it's okay well our passively get
her all our life back right Wow
yuuki-kun is a believer you know what
I'm gonna go get on my shoes I'm gonna
go get him with my stim pack all right
let's go try let's go try to save our
boy here yuuki-kun oh he left [ __ ] sorry
for that bored try your alt sure I mean
it's just a bouncy bad I think I'm gonna
die but whatever
great first match he injects Mountain
Dew game crash fixed I'm not sure
let's try again I gotta figure out how
to use him get a Spitfire I'd miss it it
was a devotion I thought
oh what's that one it's that different
crate right there they're like specific
crates
Dizzy's going to destroy people at this
character yeah probably Tyler
bizzy's pretty insane octane is not free
you have to either pay within credit
in-game credits or just buy them
normally I'm bad at this game thanks
Dobby appreciate it
he seems like a very risky character
yeah I don't know I have to figure him
out for sure he goes my first game just
messing around with the messing around
with his ability right now
the winners out there looking for you
I'll find you through that it this is
the problem that's gonna happen today
though yeah look like three different
great colors but only saw while I was
slowly or quickly rather not slowly
quickly going through the crates I only
saw two versions
what's up slow go gamer thanks for
something there is a legendary great ok
I'll have to look for it because then
you see it do you think that they'll add
another character for my shirt in there
I don't think so
but you never know launching solo
because I don't have octane and I'm a
terrible teammate
this time uses alternate alright thanks
queuing on stuff because you like my
play style that's appreciative use alt
yeah I'll try after I die here in a
second cuz there's a whole squad coming
in hot
I wouldn't have to pick the bones you
2020 oh good fire oh it's a little laggy
it's the molasses bug still has it the
the laggy one we're in the beginning of
the game it just chugs if there's too
many people or something I don't know
it's weird a bar they whatever you
battle pass level start at what level
level one unless you buy the premium one
inject then you jump at okay no problem
he cost twelve token 12000 tokens yeah
it's either 12,000 12,500 Chris Wuornos
4500 but I guess not
Wow riveting gameplay oh dang outta that
was octane I deserve that
I just 100% desert I totally thought I
was octane I was like hey guys I'm gonna
show you an octane finisher how much is
the battle past nine fifty so basically
ten bucks
his octane worth buying I mean if you
have the credits why not um I had the
credits so I think it's cool to try a
new hero his Q is a stim pack he runs I
believe 30% faster but you take damage
why don't you just quit till you get
octane I still want to play the game
like I don't want to join in like we you
you never know you get some spicy
moments
oh here we go here's his abilities if
you want to read them I need to try stim
launchpad though chat wants to see that
so we'll check that out for sure the
passive seems like pretty slow it
doesn't it's like it doesn't heal that
fast
effing solo jumper yeah sorry I'm a bad
teammate I did say that I just want to
octane today Kelvin normally I would
just kind of go and do the right thing
show the octane skins we showed a bunch
of octane skins there I love to see your
sensitivity on ps4 I think it's either
at standard rav4
[Music]
introducing there's gonna be an L star
though in the in the future it looks
like but I don't see a new gun day
another energy weapon interesting all
right
where the jumpmaster um we oh wait i'm
by myself
all right let's go die a horrible debt a
problem
see if you can stim when you jump okay
yeah on off the jump pad right stim into
jump pad right controller sensitivity is
three or four of them
I have no squad and it wasn't that I did
this on purpose
surprisingly no 37 on the contrary
I'm so bad with the r99 not gonna lie
I'm like I'm like one of the worst hard
id9 users yeah yeah no solos yet
what's up Sebastian yeah new guy can you
place the jump-out on a wall no it like
will hit has hit collision and he'll
drop onto the floor
what's up Logan I can try to pull up my
settings if someone was curious about my
sensitivity I'm pretty sure it's default
or like not that thing crap we're not
gonna get octane blep at least I don't
think we are maybe we'll
you can you can convict them you can you
can keep spamming stim it doesn't kill
you so like not that you want to be in
that position my guys but alright let's
just do some dailies show us the past I
can show you after the game we kind of
went through a bunch yeah Justin um the
lag for the early drops still exists
unfortunately using his primary attack
is risky one hit and you're dead well if
you get down that low
yeah well Soviet you can either play
some more or spend the spend the monies
I guess but I earned enough to have to
buy multiple characters I just haven't
unlocked people yeah if you're not
seeing the update on console best bet is
to restart your console and it'll show
up it took me like five ten minutes
until it showed up on ps4 for me how do
you unlock the apex banner are you
talking about the logo the apex logo if
someone has it it means they've got to
like level 100 take a lifeline with the
game
[Music]
I'll come back teammates I promise
Eric needs a gun though
good job that guy killed one guy
alright Mozambique good enough at least
we killed the Lifeline with tears octane
he's not available through the battle
pass which is like a complaint people
have suya any wins yet no we're winning
would be to get octane right now
Southtown shy orgy which is like Chicago
right I don't let me find out they did
the hitboxes
so I know they so they worked on crashes
trying to see if they okay so the level
100 havoc skin is the first ever
three-stage evolving legendary weapon
skin as you get more kills within the
match its eyes glow and its nostrils in
amid smoke that's pretty cool so so I
guess if you have a havoc that havoc
skin it'll it'll change mid-game so
that's kind of like a play on like
something like fortnight right cuz
fortnight had like skins that would
change through the game like like actual
skin skin not the gun skin I don't
understand Octane's syringe skill
basically you run faster to sacrifice
health naam that's a good try I can't
shout out your friend Nick so good try
though I have him sweat just like I
can't play him that people ticker so we
got octane hands what class is octane he
looks like a salts
he's got the assault kind of
hello bullets he's the same as Bangalore
Mirage and Wraith
I want another recon character no one
wants to have it skin that's fair I
don't doubt you on that one but yeah so
what's the in the battle patch if you
don't get octane yeah that evolving
havoc skin at 100 you are earning like
credits throughout you're also earning a
couple like apex packs you're earning
skins for guns and characters and like
quips and other stuff yeah I can go oh
shoot I'm so sorry guys I didn't go to
the battle pass I'll do that after I
still need to stim pack and jump off his
bounty pad to not really like for
tonight it's more like black ops but
didn't for tonight I have a thing where
like the skin like the actual character
skin model would evolve or change during
the match oh I just sweat off sick
momentum that's all right
oh speaking of the havoc here you go
want that riveting havoc gameplay huh
so what you guys want a turbocharger
interesting nobody dropped here flatline
flatline probably better than the havoc
so let's just get off that sorry no have
it gameplay where we go a single shot
hemlock they say me huh
and I think that yeah there's like some
XP type boost read something about to
you the stim is like yeah
tf2 or titanfall TV oh let's try stim
pack bouncy so it's kind of get farther
I guess I guess you can test that right
you test so we kind of got what like
pretty close there let's see how far we
get if we just ran normally it's pretty
similar I think I got a little bit
farther but not too much
I've never been good with the hemlock
kind of like bass excuse me
bass sight oh I was like why I not
running faster Oh
derp that was on me I've been holding
down on the stick do I have feel like
we're just finding nothing but level 2
armor huh need some purple armor we're
talking about you no no no I don't think
thanks emo love you too
slide it into the jump back here get way
more here okay I'll do that in a second
digital optical threat that's pretty
good
holy whoa that was an interesting
interaction where's the third third
somewhere here right just finish him
[Music]
they'll never know I'm down here right
kill HP Auto combat period yeah I
probably should have but I was looking
for that last guy so try aiming with
stim please okay
I'll do that in a second it's hard to
remember all that stuff right now muscle
memory is not there yet so I apologize
shot but we definitely hit that octane
when we slid by each other with the
Peacekeeper and I don't know how much it
did but I was it was funny that
Pathfinder got out though that's pretty
good on his part oh wow so the jump pads
stay which is pretty cool I guess
if you're ever gonna like come back here
I was trying to slide
somewhere over there come on oh right
there just just jumped a ditch
oh so dumb I should just went up there
got too excited seeing the other octane
don't kill me don't do it no that's not
it
yeah I killed them wait there's one more
what didn't they kill all three behind
oh he's got the speed demon
nice work escape you stim yeah that we
definitely got away with the stem which
is nice
I I screwed that up I shouldn't have
fought the guy below I shouldn't went
after the blood down on top that was
definitely a mistake this guy may die if
he doesn't he doesn't heal himself oh
he's in the ring though so that's good
no no no you why would you thirst there
definitely don't thirst when there's a
guy like right there oh we did 3:44 it's
okay Oh bad bad plays bad place I'll
admit to them his passive works while
downed that's awesome yeah that's pretty
cool
you got carried or not uh maybe
faith would be on our side for now
factor
[Music]
if you all aren't a fan of the gameplay
that's okay I get it
you don't you don't have to be here yeah
I've won multiple time so you know just
depends not good every game so you know
give me a break
[Music]
yarn are butoh sick he's definitely an
aggressive player yeah sometimes overly
aggressive can I show you guys abilities
forget it
he's got stem runs 30% faster for 10% of
his health his passive gives him HP
regeneration over time and then his alte
is the bouncy pad can you ad s shoot
while you're using the ageneral in yes
GameSpot over-explaining bro always
over-explaining
it's my life who's better octane Mirage
it's hard for me to say King Leon I
haven't played enough of octane to give
you an informed answer trying to trying
to just play competently because you
know it's really easy to judge someone
on the internet playing I guess what
it's expected it's okay I appreciate
everyone in chat regardless of they
think I am a good or bad or whatever I
just appreciate you guys being here I'm
gonna channel the power of positivity
can you bunny hops with stim I don't
know cuz I'm not playing on PC and I
don't think you can bunnyhop on ps4 that
I know of but I haven't tried either I
know it's more common on
PC because of like what you're able to
do with like waz D and so like if you
want to see a DSC lets me with stim
guessing and there's a guy there sick
and there's one there sub not son rip
what do you think is ultimate charges up
quicker than others
oh yeah for sure 100% bunny
people bunnyhop on console using bumpers
actually oh really like extra paddles or
like just like straight-up normal just
like like normal controller scheme can
you block towards with Pat that's
actually a good question I'm not sure
Oh revive
babies are fast
is probably terrible play
what's up Lacey price
all right rip everything you guys ah
who's the best legend um that's hard to
say I think if we're just if they didn't
do the hitbox stuff yet
I think Wraith technically because of
her head box but battle passes 950 do
you think his passive is the best um are
they not necessarily Mike only because
it's not that fast the passive is not
that fast and it's just to mitigate why
use med kits when he heals himself
because of how slow the heal is like you
you need to be back to full right like
I'm not gonna like run out there and
like wait for my passive show skins for
him we did that a bunch this is one of
them hang in there Eric thanks Chris
thanks thanks Chris we'll get there
we'll get there I'll get better I'll get
better terrible play well I either ditch
my teammates there or try to fight but
that was a 3 B once I type I won't win
whose ultimate is the best um I mean it
depends lifeline is good just to like
sake back up
I like bloodhounds alts a lot gibraltars
alts is technically the best from like a
damage perspective but yeah trial and
error
excuse me with this legend yeah why did
you quit so quickly because we all died
stop boosting octane he isn't really
that good I mean I haven't wait how can
you know if a hero is good or like sorry
a legend is good or bad until you
actually play him enough
Bangalore is the best she has a like
overall very solid kit though for sure
even with his even with her nerf rather
the 30% said of 40% like it's still
pretty good to just be able to like run
faster for free what is your favorite
legend huh maybe Bangalore
alkane is operate you have to buy either
with in-game credits or in-game credits
or
that was not their shoot do I get the
other guy too
we're just get one place I think you
just get one first should have crouched
Octane's 950 or 12,000 credits
alright don't shoot
there try to get this guy's banner -
[Music]
yeah I can't help you right now buddy
you want you to calm down have no shield
batteries
I'm a walking medic I guess how do you
get the update if you don't see it right
away restart your console is what I
would say
so yeah I was skimming that whole time
show the past already I showed after
this game himself Chloe wasn't by
himself though cuz he thinkin instead
the prosthetic leg thing is actually
throwing me off a little bit like the
sound of it
extended heavy bag here level two I
could go back to skull I guess try to
get a high ground you know I really
actually suck with the devotion I rather
have a spitfire any day of the week well
we do have a three time which is pretty
nice
what if we like bounce pad off here
we want to try for science kind of want
to yo we should def check out that care
package China lying on the building I
know do you feel like you should I
should be skimming like just all the
time no she feel like when I'm not
standing here
yeah that's Lisi had shield cells all
right we need a turbocharger
so glide in over there I wonder if the
you guys think they marketplace bounce
pads are still there toast wrap my
teammates going where I told them to go
doing it I have my days with the
Peacekeeper sometimes good sometimes bad
hemlock just keep the devotion down
spats are gone just think you just kept
it in the game
we need to get inside the ring pronto
pick that up in case
drop hemlock for devotion I probably
should to be honest I'll just try to
ride it out ride out that LMG life we
did use that uh we did use the hemlock
just now though for sure massive is the
best gun hi I'm hit or miss with it
personally I for me top guns for me just
me legend and battle pass
I'm are 301 are 301 like wingman are
through
it's like why anything really be helping
my team everybody just bug this is PI a
bad idea
feel like I've revived this guy wrong
back to life like these arms now
I'll show up that'll pass in a second
guys
Wow what did the arc star me what a
grenade oh what a grenade that guy was a
legend Wow
don't use your kids yeah I sure to
switch the hemlock whoever told me to
switch the hemlock I did did it revive
karma hey man
trying to be a better teammate apex
won't load after the update oh I had
that problem just kill the app Aaron and
then reopen it you'll be fine
I was trying to flank that other guy but
he killed him and then there was like a
people behind I heard I want to play
octane hilarious oh okay battle pass I
know I'm so sorry um you know what
actually let's I got I got you I got you
fam one second I totally I totally can
do this
I could totally show you both the the
we're gonna do it live
let me fire up the PC on the other
screen and then I'm gonna go swap it
back and forth okay there's that I'm
confused
I need to meet this guy's what I was
right
okay
copy that yes
okay I will show you the battle pass in
the season it's a season Wow a season
it's gonna take me ten weeks to show you
guys okay
please pick it up octane sick I heard
the Prowler it's also kind of like they
think Oh
molasses
oh there's supply ships above us that's
not a good thing so like fire we're
swimming in quick sin here look we're
not we're not swimming in quicksand
anymore I can't move thirst me guys
thirst me
why are you shooting me what is he doing
what is what is what are all right it
was because I want to show you a
seasoned battle the battle pass that
that's why I shouldn't be running out in
the open though and real in all honesty
all right battle pass oh I don't know
wait what oh I don't want to buy a
battle pass level all right so here's
the battle pass level - we're gonna get
crate
well great a gippy Pathfinder some creds
some coins some hot coin they say you
you earn enough coins by playing this to
get another battle pass which is good
there's all level 25 you got a Apex
legendary crate let me see if there's a
where's the gold crate that's just a
normal one it's a rare one Prowler skin
that one looks cool oh here it starts
that you start to get a hundred once
you're past fifty some of the basic
skins are kind of whatever ooh that
looks cool i guess i'm i really wish
they had oh here's your here's your
legendary one so you get one legendary
pack for sure
at level 86 so there you go and if you
still want to see more of that i can
always switch back and forth I have my
PC up on the side here that has it open
as well now the wraith was good the
wraith had 1,300 kills the life line i
don't know what he was doing but i
shouldn't have got killed to begin with
can't blame a few minutes blame poor
player myself oh no please no
huh kids why are you not in school why I
tell your teachers I don't know
[Music]
the battle castes
ah you don't need the battle pass
necessarily I can't open it you got to
get to the high-level show this game's
brew I have one of the legendary skins
which is the racer so here here is uh
here's the skins as we go through the
game speed demon all right guys we pack
the game all right I need a mute this
guy we're gonna skull we're going to
skull baby
the bow pass takes so long to unlock
experience-wise WTF I think you got to
do certain challenges to help out I
think like if you play a match with oh
that's not good
stim oh 7,000 kills
that's the highest I've seen on
PlayStation ever octane is like a
support because he can speed himself and
he's all can really help people I think
he's a flanker like he he quickly like
repositions and gets on top of you I
think wait it's Rob actually playing no
I think J boogie you're actually
leveling the battle pass it's not like
you're like just level level it's yeah
it's like another X like a separate XP
tree can you shoot whilst and yes hello
rekt yes I got destroyed absolutely
shred by that hour 301
holy [ __ ] Jim sniped now probably not I
got destroyed though balanced gameplay
nah that was just I got out skilled
sponsored by Nike alright first eSports
athletes new founders get discount on
the ballot past that I don't know of
f-bomb so you'd have to double-check
that is all came slower than other
characters I don't think so I thought
that everyone's mousse speed was the
same but I'm not 100% sure on that one
that's just what I thought Rob told me
but that's like almost like me throwing
Robin
bustle dislike
only discount with EI origin yeah
so you do get that for sure so does l1
make you run fast and what's the past
okay so l1 gives you a speed bonus here
let me try to pull this other screen up
just show you his abilities that okay so
you can't see it because of the oh there
you go so you have Swift man stim and
Launchpad now I got switched back to
this you want me to go to the hot zone
it's so far though alright we can hit
about a thousand
what's up levy or Levi
I love the triple tape I haven't hit him
this with it for sure it's pretty good
gun though
I got us pretty close I kind of screwed
up a little bit not gonna lie
I got a P let's kill them all my
favorite gun or one of my favorite guns
thanks I guess I took all of that damage
for you okay that's like a head shield
battery extend away this guy not is
there really no Harlan should give him
that pack oh did he have a scope at all
passage for you guys though for that
little bit of top off keep forgetting
about that passive alright you just gain
life over time with the passive I guess
there was no high tier loot here
or we just didn't get it I'm really bad
with the Spitfire red dot or the iron
sight right dot whatever you want to
call it I think it's just iron sight
this piece we're not it's updated I
won't be as for why did 3x go to my hem
walk it's not looted it's gonna be
really tough got a war
Seki row is out this week days gone next
next month I think April but uh pretty
different games all excluded I think
that back
it's definitely looted people have been
here
I think someone's been here hopefully
they still are because I'm bored
it's a great line maybe it's just my own
breathing nope nope that was a
bloodhound
I think someone's been here
hopefully they still are because I'm
bored oh he bounced padded up that's
actually sick that's actually sick that
was a great play by that guy he he
jumped had it up to me you know what
would have been funny if I happen to put
a jump pad there too damn unfortunate Oh
Rob we got Reb chickie Oh bingo
um I thought y'all was bad should have
used Alt alt to where though like where
was I all ting like the only thing I
could have saw there was like alt to
like stop him from like getting up to us
I don't know those are those if he all
if I if he did what I think he did which
was the enemy octane I'm pretty sure he
altered it to jump up to me he did the
thing you didn't do yeah but I wasn't
where was I gonna alt to you know so
what's going on what's up Rob we are
playing the new legend octane I bought a
skin for him well with my with my
crashing part and also checking out the
season pass that's funny Trent because
I've won multiple times so I can't be a
complete detriment octane is passive if
you want to see it I think I still have
it up on the screen here's the other my
other game that's up Swift mend stim
launch bad
those are his abilities and just in a
second here will probably pop back over
to main gameplay features as I try to
get better I do appreciate the folks
hanging out giving the advice or giving
tips I appreciate it
just use all because you haven't seen it
gotcha no problem if we live I will do
my best
also mirage decoys can also jump at
that's cool
I am landing here
his octane free No
crapping panda it's just what the
internet does when they have a voice you
give him a voice and then you kind of
got a little molasses mode yeah its
molasses mode gg7
get hype Rob says he's so laggy feels
good it's gonna get better right
we slow-mo killed them I can't even get
away this is my slide look at him throw
that away like it's nothing so how you
guys doing you know just me sitting in a
tar pit essentially left down there
cancel that that guy's your battle pass
let's do it
from where I died it was definitely
behind me he's right there Daniel just
look for the job postings and see if
there's one open for you all right we
killed the Gibby I don't know that that
thing still hasn't changed the laggy
stuff the Boost cost health yes ten
percent but you can technically get it
back oh look at him playing with his leg
fix it himself
no you can't kill yourself Luka I tried
that earlier you can keep spamming it at
low HP and you don't lose anything let
me show you guys the skills if you want
to see him up just kidding I was
disconnected I can fix that though - I
have two going on right now so there's
this one and let's get to the legends I
can't click actually I guess I could've
did it on this screen - but alright he
is not ready and I don't know if I have
the patience to wait so Rob hit me up
when you're ready or just join me back
when you're ready octane is not
exclusive to the battle pass he is a
separate thing that you have to buy
either with in-game credits or gold
every time I've used his stem I haven't
used it right I think I was trying to go
engage that other fight but I should
just be smarter about this skins for him
sure so we have gold rush there's El
Diablo there's speed demon victory lap
which is basically like gold rush and
then these are all though like you know
your standard I would really wish the
epics were cooler kind of like overwatch
where they're like slightly different
not not legendary level but like just
different
he has the same amount of skins as
everyone else thoughts on Google's new
gaming system I haven't been out there
to watch mr. medic I've been playing or
trying to play octane as much as I could
can one else know hitbox on his legs I
don't know I've died already quick with
them mute that guy in a second once I
can I'm gonna turn down gameplay for now
though uh we're not gonna get him
someone else has them octane is passive
is to get life back
don't do it pick caustic you know what
just for that I'm playing Gibby
just for that I am playing give
Gibraltar do you think he's worth buying
of vive boyo e for me he is because it's
just a new flavor to the game and I want
to get you know figure him out get
better with them so yeah I think it's
worth it but you know again if you're if
you have some mainstays already that you
like playing then like I wouldn't worry
too much about it
students brothers today both drop so low
I'm not concerned I'm playing
Gibby
Oh Gold wingman probably gonna die now I
like some armor please okay my biggest
complaint about the gold weapons is the
Scopes every one of them has such a
terrible scope I do have on what am i oh
let's go fight fight guess they don't
want to fight guess I'm just gonna have
to go do it myself do we keep his armor
thing though that's the question now
we're not gonna arm shield oh oh
Givi is big body big lovable body okay
alright third guys so far
take my gold wingman I missed those
three shots I tried to get headshots
that's why mistakes were made
should you just win for that big body
all right can I get the race skin by
just playing ah that's a good question
actually I should go look loud doors are
allowed in this game yeah
where is octane I'm trying to get them
it's tough when you're so low squatting
or solo queuing see like Louise oh my
god is gonna want octane unless I have a
higher pick so this is how it goes yep
I punish my teammates by playing Gibby
you take my octane I take
I still might have to fight with that
smiling robot how just kidding he's fine
everyone's fine
champion in case you didn't know you get
here by winning good luck what's all in
the battle pass skins gunskins banners
you get some packs you also get some
coins is he gonna make the game less
redundant not necessarily it's just like
kind of has made a different meta if any
it's annoying if there's boss on your
team they that actually come confirm
though on the bots thing I hear people
say
I wonder if you can bounce a trap or if
your captor stays on it and you can't
even use the bouncy pad anymore as a
sniper scopes do you mr. hello Farah
Yolo don't care good job good job good
job
devotion is too slow it's like I feel
like you have to like pre-fire with the
devotion you should buy coins III don't
need to rich is the best character she's
got the best hitbox unless the hitbox
came in the hitbox fix came in but I
don't know if it did I don't know if you
get the free skins Morgan I can check
though and pull up this feed real quick
yep not getting octane boys and girls I
think you'd have to either buy it or get
it from the packs potentially that
when wow this guy needs to calm down
anyways thank you guys all guys and gals
for tuning in to GameSpot live we're
playing apex legend she's checking out
the season pass checking out some octane
what is your opinion octane cute little
early for me to tell unfortunately seems
like could be fun though and good
flanker I think my one friend here is
gonna like him a lot
he likes the flank so I don't know be
interesting haven't played enough of it
for sure
what do you think about the three
schemes there okay like anything else
like the only cool looking skins really
are the legendaries every other scheme
is kind of just whatevs to me I'm gonna
take octane from me and then drop in my
building big revive game plays here
why did my teammate run you got a
peacekeeper bro all right no more
reviving people got a place selfishly
just kind of play selfishly gotta play
selfishly y'all all right we got his
outlaw skin she'd been using that this
whole time can you turn off the ability
when you activate it
I don't think so Daniel ninja was
watching you oh yeah ninja is watching
you okay that's cool I guess
watching a mediocre gameplay our offense
ability as useful as other characters I
think so I I think jump pad is
situational but definitely can be pretty
good Marko wrong nationality actually
Dex lid says was watching oh that's cool
that's fine that's fair cool ban me my
squads gonna beat up your squad
as the battle pass worth it I think if
you want to you know chase some skins
chase some other stuff and like
never gonna quit Jerry I enjoy the game
too much
but thank you for stopping by appreciate
you coming in so chad and hang out and
all that fun stuff thank you thank you
thank you for the view appreciate it
there's a lot of people here some hair
boys is a blue
I'm eating shotgun ammo
I am repairing myself gotta hop up here
joke that some reason I thought of
something else anybody need energy Elmo
shocked and a backpack I guess I'll go
bunker
does the injection animation prevent
firing Lloyd you can still a.m.
mm I don't know about like right off the
bat but probably loot it outside this
right
I'll really dive this wiring where's our
control you're sensitive we set up I
think either three or four
I think defaults three right here
a backpack living on eight stacks
poverty life you guys want the bounce
pad right let me see if I can block the
door with it or do you guys want to
actually see it being used there let's
try a few things so there's that right
alright so one can you nope does not
block doors
I know right fun pretty fun right
kicking back packing the inventory yeah
probably
nothing
our trio one light demo here the wrong
thing what do you think is over here
other guy going whatever me and J Blatz
here yeah we are currently playing the
season one battle pass I'm currently
playing octane the new legend who is
12000 ish credits or 950 thousand coins
I can't remember Eric K events is about
to start yeah jump into season one for
tonight
FX legends we're ready playing
PlayStation I don't know why it's at 12
maybe that was the original time and
then now it's changed I'm playing on ps4
what does Tim do it does this you run
faster you can still aim see you look
I'm still a me
I'll pull the plug wiser sure barrel
stabilizer here level three well no
Megatron our 301 here extended light
back here number one I really don't like
to for 2x4 it's dope but deal hopefully
we can find a hollow 1x some type of 1x
scope
got a hop up here select-fire I know why
I heard the tips slow ass reactions
anyways if it was two footsteps six
squads left thanks Dylan glad you think
that way the jump pad actually was
pretty cool crooks
definitely situational but someone
definitely used it to get up top on me
maybe I should take the level three
I don't really like a little three
though I should not have the heavy
extended though I don't like how he says
1x because it says right there it reads
one-time scope dude 1x1
literally 1x is in Octane's ability to
the same as bangalore passive yeah
except you get to you get to trigger it
no matter what though like even if
someone's not aiming at you
and technically bangalore's passive was
40% now 30% right
who's ready to fly on a supply
it's like you got to imagine like how
did he get up there it's sliding not
help me out there once means one times
bro come on why can he get higher
what okay maybe my trajectory is bad on
this week's episode how long will it
take Eric to get up top to the top never
impossible
honestly yeah obviously don't know how
they made it up there is it because he's
a taller character probably a guy
because of this see he can't make it
over either he grappled that make sense
I didn't go I almost got it off the
collision okay I really wish I had jump
pattern all right you guys ready for a
big place for a hopefully big place oh
that's way too far
the biggest place right the biggest of
place not very big uh-oh kind of massive
this guy's rocking the same set up arc
star yeah I should have oh that would
have been fun
jump up arc star do we get what the
Mastiff whoa is the massive have more
ammo now
no are you kidding me
that's so unfortunate that is so sad
took too long looting that story of my
life Aki Jai White's no don't go that
way come on
you can be the hero Jai Blatz you can be
the hero he's inside no don't scan the
area
you just killed yourself stimming no I
was trying to stim to get out and I was
literally one bullet away from getting
out I would have died faster if I didn't
stim I'm almost positive of that
you're like the only stream that I can
find using octane well it's subject to
actually getting him or not like the the
amount of passive rechart like life
regen is pretty slow should have jumped
out of the ledge instead of running
around yeah probably in hindsight yes
yes now that you're dead it's called a
jump pad for a reason jump on to it okay
he only runs faster when he uses the
stim
yeah one pull it up yeah it was
definitely it definitely hit my backside
oh come on packs Pete I will play a
mirage skin I guess so I'm gonna have to
uh I'm gonna have to just make it a
spicy one so it can get octane don't you
think they should make his ulti recharge
faster there be like probably too many
jump pads on the on the map it was
pretty fast actually
the man has high-octane magic yeah
if you enter a game and get a kill I
would donate we don't take donations
though but thank you you guys still
experience this crashes I haven't gotten
crashes I've gotten the slowdown bug
though
I didn't change my life school
because Octane's healing ability working
the storm and should
Battle pass is 950 coins
character is either 12,000 in-game
credits or you buy it with coins I
really hate the earth that was a bad
drop in if you ever went water that was
super far from Vegas
oh that's a wingman wingman over here
should have took my octane I should save
the day you walked right past a
legendary knock down shield it's okay I
don't wanna I don't even want to revive
I want to play oxtail
has that been modified anything not that
Oh
gameplay wingman uh wingman that's bad
do you think the tactical ability is
better for the last resort or for
situational uh I think it's situational
you can flank with it is what I perceive
or have tried to do it's good for
getting out of jail
maybe stats did not reset no I should
have just hit fired it no bueno
I agree Larry no bueno alright none of
these guys have octane thinking later
crime Thank You
console aim yeah well I aim the same way
on PC regardless sometimes you just
don't have it sometimes the wingman it
feels like a God in your hand sometimes
the wingman
feels like you just can't hit a shot to
save your life the wingman is a cruel
mistress yes I agree can you ping
launchpads I believe so
[Music]
yes that's our just different for battle
pal I remember that
there's our six skin let's do it
I feel good this is gonna be the one I
thought that one where we had the met
like Mastiff potentially was gonna be
the one but it was not the case in-game
currency was twelve thousand can urine
legend tokens after a level 100 I think
he's I'm not sure I'm not a hundred yet
Larry's sick Millions
thanks for the sub during dinner if the
wingman uh I think the a little bit I
don't know cascade as much as bit any
legend basically yeah star-lord
do you have to buy octane yes but you
can do it with the in-game credits or
you can just pay I'll write Apex coins
for them
and guys split off
man there's a level-two over there he's
probably gonna go get it right if I've
taught you to it
come on stim oh it's only been here
thinking this place has already been
sacked horrible death
I need armor someone out there willing
to trade buy armor got shot trying to
jump on my jump head because someone
told me to jump on the jump pad and I
like attempted dad and that was a big
mistake
what do you see what do you see
[Applause]
triple take paid for it
hate the thirst in new today but I'm
gonna die that was a great double arc
star by whoever that was no need weapons
it
how much is octane 12,000 or 950 coins
the passive healing seems slow yeah it's
it's pretty slow apparently has a
history with life one octave e o Silva
use air to be occupied CEOs of silver
pharmaceuticals and so this day he
decided to set the course record for
nearby gauntly by launching himself
across the finish line using a grenade
as he laid in triage hours later the
doctors informed him that the damage
done to his life daredevil days he's 24
there's a pad v spawn it didn't look
like it triple takes his buns
yeah there's gonna be the L star I think
wiki Scott they teased it I just don't
know when it's going to be
Oh
going inside
all right guys dead she's dropped with
us perhaps she should have dropped with
us
stim again that gotta be really mindful
about how I hold the d-pad down please
feel like I'm not always running when I
should be
I was very dangerous looting but it
worked out we got the banner leader
watch your six
I feel like they did right here there's
two there's three it's not good god
please shoot
nope
I was my the trigger was getting stuck
so it wasn't like actually firing up all
the [ __ ] hey look I got a battle pass
level too let's open a pack he cost the
same as Mirage yes oh that's sweet sweet
yeah quite terrible yeah that's pretty
bad okay see so like this is my men in
black tulle I'm gonna flash you never
saw anyone said no closest was like top
three I think yeah down single firework
yeah yeah I know I wanted it on single
fire yeah yeah it's true spacer not a
good not a good enough reason
blame it on the sticks always got a
bling on the sticks now that was my
fault it's always easier yeah Tony see
that's how it goes man everyone's a god
when they're not the one being judged
for playing you know but then when they
judge but okay power of positivity can't
shake me can't stop me the battle pass
was nine fifty as well basically $10
octane out of ten
hard to say Alex my dude are open Oh
Bobo about how we're going to
being instead
yeah I'll try to unstick each others
just have fun with it homey thank you
rigid collision normally I would just
run in probably should it's okay we got
an arc star so that's something and only
these scraps are probably where you left
them
look how slow that health comes back all
I got three ninja stars war ninja stars
oh wow that was a mistake I didn't open
that one I guess you've got a backpack
level four
that's like fire let's get a prowler huh
oh boy backpack level four would have
been real nice why is it that I've never
actually gotten on top of the roof like
that other than with
huh well compadre his name is padre
where the odds
all right all right we have four
shocking shots left
need more it all worked out in them
Eva Eva strong you've a strong shot dude
we didn't kill that Octavian either or I
didn't see if I have someone revived in
my box would be over there yes rings
right there up here your pipe payment
mm-hmm 45 seconds still rings nose
amigos
don't make me carry you on okay I need
heavy amo
that's hilarious often
thirty Seconds rings closed
this is painful to watch
well sorry wrong channel then you got
the wrong place my dude I use octane
earlier clean your inventory this gold
shield have passive if you execute you
get shield back assuming you're missing
shields I he's worth it to me on a
personal level because having a new
character is fun but the ultimates kind
of situational somebody did use it
really good against really well against
me earlier they knew I was high ground
and they used it to get to high ground I
almost had a good example of it to kind
of doing it back to someone else but my
peacekeeper shots didn't hit for that
much unfortunately
otherwise it was in pretty sick
I'm sure someone's gonna do some nutty
stuff care package business
gobble-gobble heavy
bori shields here level three we all
have level three all right well this is
looks like one of those games where you
just got to got to do it
trying to find trouble though find any
and I say that I'm part gonna die here
they're relieved with my teammates here
would really like a scope what's your
fov I'm just playing standard I think
everything's on
oh you guys wanted to know about the
passive right maybe it doesn't work top
really shyness go
because they have a small hitbox I don't
know guys seems like it his legs must be
hard to shoot Oh bloodhound all that's
100% bloodhound all finishing up
this is riveting gameplay right six
squads left right now someone just
called the care package now I don't know
press escape I can time play I'm playing
on ps4 I know please draw all the
attention here I would really greatly
appreciate it where's the next circle oh
geez
pretty far
alright let's just start going yes
please don't be above me feel like I
heard someone die up there earlier
behind you rip in pepperonis
so in trouble I screwed up I took too
long killing the bloodhound this is
camping 101 yeah see what happens when
we stop camping big trouble big trouble
alkane is not free not free to climb
there we could try it I don't think it
makes you look you higher do you try
using your stem then fall from a high
and see if you're unaffected by the path
oh you mean by the like a sprat
contrived well it's tough when you're so
low cueing and like people want to stay
in a building because like I guess I
could push them needed to push with your
team yeah but they looked like they
wanted to play very passive the best
character actually to pull other players
when you're so low squatting is rave
because you can use the portal and you
kind of force them to fall with you
where legends would work well with
octane in Europe you might be able to
pull Bangalore just so you smoke so that
he can flank
maybe Pathfinder because you could maybe
do some cool like jump pad grapple stuff
I'm still curious like what you can do
with like a caustic rap like I don't
think you you don't get octane at the
valve pass was the point of getting it
it's just if you want to get the rest of
the
Wow wingman I'm so sorry everyone shot I
just wanted to use the jump pad oh I
kind of stim I tried to stim out I
should've did it sooner oh that was kind
of fun that's a fun game those misses
were not so fun play I should have I
should have killed the guy in the
building those looting I think I was so
sure I was just gonna like body shot
that Pathfinder that was like right next
to me I was like hello hello should've
just 80s Mozambique here
I appreciate everyone's patience though
you know sometimes it just doesn't go
the way you want it to finish her please
okay I'll try I did it earlier Mike
because I don't want to like lose health
I guess you're a show the finisher so I
could do that
well actually it's fight disconnected
I'll pull it up on this other screen
real quick
so here's finisher number one throws
like the grenades and then here's
finisher number two so yeah
the I don't think the higher level
battle pass for 28 bucks is with it
anyways um yeah I don't think the $28
ones worth it
he needs dizzy dizzy would probably put
me in his backpack and I would do
nothing and watch him kill people
probably watch her Raptor poster so dad
nice little setup thank you yeah you can
find that poster pretty easily which
controller to use I'm just using his
work alright
I don't think this guy knows that he's
not getting it to where he wants to get
to so
hey you guys wanted me to try like a
sprint right until like dropping
headshot and once
time
you're like you went to the roof
don't you through the window please
so hopefully those plays right there
that I just made make up for some of the
bad plays earlier okay next shot
love you love all you should probably
get off this P 2020 though I don't even
know if I Mozambique's better your storm
chipper snipe I should go loot I don't
know it's not looted though
well the hemlock do try again chat you
got to get that right away the reality
got to get better with single-shot
hemlock it's it's a it's a thing just
got to treat it like it's the g7 scout
against my are you gonna join the
division the dab the brill
I actually am NOT playing the division
to you right now I got super burnt out
of looting games after I played anthem
and so I needed a break
played a bunch of Apex kind of been
playing this other game too that I can't
talk about yet we'll come back tomorrow
we'll talk about a little bit more no
let's go find trouble make it double so
we have to pay for the battle class that
doesn't include character yes if you
want to you don't have to obviously Dan
Haru King just killed two guys with a
Spitfire so weird this place doesn't get
leading amazing
they're shooting from like over there
right or were they just fighting a
bunker pick up the grenade but choose
not to up hey guys over there enemies
spotted over there oh we gotta go
circles coming
nope go company and they're not here by
reviving the rate though
there's behind and in front i am i agen
chinese huh 7:22 damage
I tried did they already do the update
yes maybe I should have just rehe 'ls
and not engaged in I fight cuz I don't
know I lit that one guy up but and I lit
the Bangalore up too but then he ran
into the portal and then I probably
shouldn't have chased him at that point
but then our teammate died so I don't
know all around the old Pinscher arrow
pinch arrow yeah and Cheerios corrects I
think the Bangalore got into the one
that I was chasing anyone staying
unfortunately let's go already
the effort it is true that Bangalore
like if her passive triggers it's pretty
much the same thing as a skin tone and
you don't lose life so I don't know she
don't want to tilt the tower you mean
skull town I should have also healed up
probably yeah
I could a Phoenix skidded I guess how do
you rank up battle pastors objectives
and experience as you get its pincher
room yeah this is it this is the win
Jesus look at skull town
well then beat here and walk Redemption
terrible longbow action who's ready for
some terrible longbow action I know I am
Caine let's go baby a wingman I missed a
level two back
someone else will take it it's fine why
why can't it be a heavy mag even a blue
one would have been fine all right
why did that just sound like someone
tweeting me okay because we're scared
the bejesus out of me no action
this is the best favorite weapon do it
whoo tough probably our 301 Evo right
now it is because I've just been having
bad luck with the Peacekeeper even
though it didn't okay earlier and having
bad luck with the wingman is the chat
scene
like I was hands a gun actually thought
I was dumb at first but it's it's it's
like hey I don't have a gun in my hand
maybe I should we can't buy octane drugs
I don't know man
they probably don't exist in this
universe
oh did it kind of stop this play the
dude took the backpack I called dibs
spit fire boys and girls we are off the
hemlock plan and onto the Spitfire plan
you think it's the faster faster brand
of drugs probably why we've seen nobody
they all the one like skull is that
liquefied if you use that pumps into his
blood I don't think we'd would make you
run that fast
we got the level two backpackers garlis
that wasn't a gold knock down anything
my eyes betray me
so chambo backpack here are 99 here
she's fast like me she's talking about
life line or do you think he's actually
like talking about when I pinged it
where is the action there's been so much
heavy everywhere spit comes out pretty
so I'm going to the care package why not
what do you think is over here dang dude
my teammates are so far behind his alt
is a jump pad yes
jump right over it
well I'm kind of curious if jumping on
it as I say if jumping on it even makes
it go away faster whatever or a higher
faster faster
here
precision our choke down my teammates
choke gosh leave me alone spin around
and thingy we'll never know huh
do you think he'll know that we're
dropping in on them
I really dumb for the chat no I wanted
to take his armor so I didn't have to
recharge my batteries all right sorry
she come on
that player on track oh there's a care
package on the other side of us I know
it's pretty far all this kind of lame
yeah I don't know
there's gonna be applications for sure
I'm sure the streamers will figure it
out and get some cool stuff
where's everyone else at let's check out
over there
it's go time
does anyone like the battle pass the
havoc sounds cool but you gotta get to a
hundred to try it out so I don't know oh
dang it
I would've been sick
what's his tactical again it's the
stimpak that maybe run faster at the
cost of 10% oh yeah yeah passive is like
he gets life back slowly like regen does
the finger guns do anything actually I
don't think so but oh gosh you're back
there you want to fight them I want to
know this play no you can punch though I
was hoping he'd do like a bang bang or
something man is my team gonna camp
again
so you can pay health to have
bangalore's ability pretty much except
you control it though there so that's I
know I think that's the cool part time
to look for trouble
how's the launchpad I think it's okay
I think there's applications for it but
I haven't found great use for it yet
this special deal down there's two
[Applause]
[Applause]
sergeant mi chigan sir there's a white
wine paavana tequila we've got a care
package here
that not even attainable okay Phoenix
get here got a helmet here me Wilson
oh yay any room wow you've revived them
really fast there we're screwed
don't do it I wonder if I was a team
that was aiming at me earlier yes you
can shoot while in speed mode yes
first shot was great did 100 next next
shot only did 72 so it took it took
missed one shot hit him with the fourth
but then was pretty lit at that point
and then bloodhound came and cleaned me
up probably sure you just swapped a
Spitfire and fought him so like these
guys are just hanging out here I mean
when you see double care package you
know the teams coming I feel like this
guy is not even gonna bother we should
just leave or I'm about to leave does he
shoot at this guy and then die
yep his nerve shaky hands oh so we see
this is the this is the battle path
stuff so octane legend bonus total XP
they tried to do some more octane
I think the steam should do a little
less damage but yeah but I guess it's
yeah because it's so fast and you can
use it so often I feel like it should be
a little bit less
you can call me nuthouse
maybe pygmy octane what power level
growing slowly we're getting there
getting better again thank you guys and
gals all for tuning in to GameSpot live
normally we're live at 11 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time today we went a little bit
early because of the season pass and
season 1 pet battle pass and also
because Octane's out really appreciate
everyone hanging out and being patient
as I try to get a little bit better with
octane so appreciate it no wins yet
today we're just unfortunates usually we
get one on stream when we stream but no
success yet unfortunately
supply ship over there
what I need to do really quickly is just
to make sure I am good
his passive is heal over time his
tactical is impact which allows them to
run 30% faster about the cost of 10
health
I guess there dude jumped off
none of them are actually free nothing
is free battle pass isn't free and the
character is technically not free either
you can buy them with in-game currency
if you have it but obviously you would
have needed to you know purchase or have
played enough or saved enough up to this
point where you do have it or 99 here
here
our Spitfire is I think get it out yeah
mostly kid it out
how's Alan launch pad on octane nabretta
it is good for certain situations I
think but I haven't really gotten too
great with it yet curious to see what
the community does with it I'm sure
they're gonna think of some cool things
apparently you can deep you can send a
mirage do you off of it stand their sake
which is pretty cool
three men kids those folks right for
making med kit
I know we should test
right now wanted to test to see if he
had the splat with the stim or not
I've seen nobody what's it dropped far
these keepers better than Eva it is if
you're accurate with it Eva just gives
me a greater chance to succeed so you're
not wrong that Eva in the right hands is
better than ours Rea that a peacekeeper
in the right hand is better than the Eva
in my hands a little suspect
moving now
stim doesn't seem fast is 30%
he revived just for its upon dropship
coming in amigos got the battery huh but
don't we need one big I guess I want to
go fight darkness but don't look like
that's the case there's another gun
coming I eventually the yellow star I'm
sure they're figuring out pacing
thinking this place has already been
sacked scratch that
yeah another dropship hell yeah clothes
half the squads are tossed I just look
for trouble ya know I was so sure that
there'd be action
should I get the battle pass I think
it's up to you ninja if you owe any real
close about time we got ourselves a
fight
we could check out here
I sure just open fire I didn't think
she's by herself mistakes were made chat
bad news have been through here
[Applause]
long way to kill time with just have it
like few spots sweet
you got bamboozled my friend I've been
lied to
[Applause]
classic trap death box here
whatever sick of this
though 45 seconds still ring close
amigos don't nearly carry you
I'm getting carried I don't know about
that octane I'm pretty sure we're
getting carried
why don't you use a portal yeah there
you go
there's our level reset now put your gun
away when you run yeah well sometimes
I'm afraid that there's people I got the
jitters man too much stimpak she reviews
alts on the top of the hill to fight
those guys I was trying to get around
and wrap around
I clearly went the wrong way pros
approach I don't I sense sarcasm somehow
in that comment
I mean we have the lutely one is just
sorry I haven't done anything really
it's been a slow game to be honest
energy amo here
objects here close range
and then that guy's gotten two kills
with havoc fire select fire for a havoc
select fire will level mi like 80
something on ps4 and like 50 something
on PC
we've got trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
I know still waiting always waiting
feels bad oh I should have I almost
killed the guy those crosthwaite Lee
kind of killed the guy I almost killed
the guy across the way almost killed
killed did kill one I don't think I
would have killed that Mirage I was
stuck in reloaded probably sure just
like quick swaps he still would've
killed me probably though cuz he very
much like one one tapped me for probably
like 90 to 100 oh I probably should have
mmm I don't know what I could have
really did there maybe stim and like run
should kept the Spitfire out and not the
Eva yeah I guess I guess I could have
just Eva the Wraith maybe killed her
faster getaway possibly and then reset
the fight you're really good at watching
the stream though so Daniel I thank you
for watching the stream and that's the
same with O'Reilly I thank you for
watching the stream as well I appreciate
it
Mirage would killed me I think yeah I
think I was in trouble either way that
would have actually been hilarious if I
could have like put the trap down to
bouncing but we're in such close
quarters
respiratory's I think I would have died
in ways I don't know where these guys
going I wish i
no time from the gaming I turned down
the guy was talking to
honestly don't on like a Pentagon oh
there you go now their king Oh sick
get me out of here
hello for Kazakhstan hello thanks for
tuning in from so far away appreciate
all y'all despite some of the negativity
I will P 2020 let's go get hype please
how is it that we got purple armor
though we got a P 2020
we're already in the ring Oh looks like
markets safe for those gentlemen Daniel
swapped his tone boys Angie just take
the choke in case what do you at the
battle pass don't sleep on the B 2020 I
do not your your you're not wrong my
conchos means p22 is 2020 rather is uh
it's pretty good actually
but you know considering all the looting
I was doing it is kind of weird to have
not done a better gun but whatever Wow
dude as far okay all right it's fine
how do you like octane
I'm liking him so far I don't know where
he sits though in terms of like where I
would put him I need to see better use
cases for results clearly I'm just not
doing a good job which I will admit to
Tim seems pretty good but as chat has
mentioned
Bangalore's passive is basically like
his stim now obviously with stim you can
control it and when you're using it but
still use the wingman best gun oh man
did you see my wingman name earlier not
hot
oh we have a bat finder though my bad we
go check out here he's attacked all cool
I want to see it
sure we'll say I always don't pick up
knockdowns I better pick it up I really
don't want to pick up our t1 but ok I am
just so bad with our 300
Wow I got absolutely no oh it's two
teams or two guys rather come on Jay boy
I'll block him all the travel plays oh
that would have been so sick if he
pulled that off
oh man they're selling cookies don't
shoot yeah I guess so
ah I should have looked always get to
tunnel vision me
so I like to have a little fun so what
[Music]
no cluster foxtrots in my I think is
passive could be a little bit better it
could be for the team if you want to try
to get some high ground but then you
could also then argue like why wouldn't
you just use pathfinders zipline so I
don't know
I think is passive could be a little bit
better just considering how much you
lose 10% and you're probably gaining
like like a percent not even in per
second
please use these abilities okay do you
need to buy the new guy yes how long
have you been streaming for oh we
started at 10 so two and a half hours so
while chillin chillin with everyone in
chat on the jumpmaster I'm so sorry
we're gonna try to go there there's only
two of us sick
gonna be a party looks like as it always
is in skull town
there's a person in front of us
all right well here's wingman
peacekeeper first blood tastes like
victory he peaced out huh try to play a
little smarter
[Music]
I was terrible on so many fronts
right into the trees yeah yeah just just
get me out of here
something that spray-and-pray I know
right
I couldn't spray any harder I should
just use wing man all right we're gonna
play one more game I'm gonna do I'm
gonna channel all my energy and it's
probably still not gonna help but we're
gonna do it anyways great octane please
uh I don't know I can't I've only played
two hours with them and I can't tell you
oh here we go the Peacekeeper hotness
that was not the hotness I think I might
subscribe to you yeah Sir Gerald says
mate I know I know
[Music]
yeah let out still the only Recon
character I don't wish I was another one
you could have just popped on the
Peacekeeper yeah probably
uh I've told this story multiple times
but I feel like with the Peacekeeper and
the wingman like I feel that I I can
feel every shot I miss and each shot
spirals my confidence down even more and
so when I miss one it hurts I miss - I
hurts even more missed three it just
like I can't it just basically gets
worse and worse and worse and worse and
worse
ser Gerold I did show y'all
okay who's your main I normally play
between lifeline Bangalore and then
either bloodhound or Mirage
one of those folks say more than be sick
no Armour who did you see you're so far
I mean just look there it is coming
[Music]
no I got two there's one left
mr. cheezy blocker I'll block her
movements I'll limit her movements no I
will play one more I tried I tried to
get them all then I was like indecisive
about switching between guns and I
should have just switched guns Sooners
you're taking along well I would have
missed even more if I if I had swapped
to my g7 after I ran out of bullets in
the Eva I would have had a chance you
really really slowly
yeah well it's a controller man I'm
trying is he good now I'm pretty
mediocre I'll be the first one to admit
it all right have fun Ivan no
I play cleans as raid like your rating
[Music]
introducing your champion
[Music]
do you read YouTube chat Saul I'm
reading Isaac
12,000 or 950
rape mirages as a solo legend and not
helping other teammates and I'll cry
likely out there
here we go
on a scale of a bad drop time to
embarrass myself with the Peacekeeper
again go to the ship for the last round
[Applause]
I got some bad guys here does he not
just strike right here I still don't
have armor he's like hey they're here
let's go back for our buddy
[Music]
yes I know dude I know watch that one
guys
[Applause]
I'm so sorry my dude for seconds I can
buycks all right I said I'd go to the
plane so we'll go dropship I tried but
what what what's 4/20 forget your body
who keep them yeah I should have took
off but I don't know I figured maybe I
can like fight back and get him but
there's too many people
if you scope you deal more damage yeah I
had the choke heal up I ran out of heals
use both shield cells then see em
there's a lot of action going around me
so is gonna be tough regardless are the
new hit boxes I haven't noticed it too
much I am seeing it either too much so
yeah I guess I coulda got out but
probably not to you all right let's do
it
let's go dropship here
[Music]
how do you have a legendary I just
bought I had I had 20 and 400 credits or
something can use the harvest like an
actual dead player like I'm dead don't
you need a PA no what's that what's that
Chris this is my price range
am i dead inside a little bit
- yeah
never use at all it only takes one
minutes a car yeah but wouldn't what am
I gonna use it for
I guess I could have used the all to
like jump onto the roof or something or
to get away
am I gonna miss the [ __ ]
gonna be close
yep
you got armor I did it what are you
gonna do all to lunch we bought the ship
that would actually be funny I feel like
sometimes you feel like like you get
like registered numbers and then like
you look at your damage done and you're
like that's not right cuz like at the
end there I hit them for 72 right or
like what looked like 72 and it said I
only did 108 I launched solo because
people wanted to go to the people wanted
me to land on the ship you know good
game bro I know right you got it
I just got a audio is down because I got
a mute for now who soloist launches on
the ship I don't know me a crazy man hey
the chat wanted the chat wanted the ship
so I went to the ship
can it down to enemy or partner use your
jump at that's actually a good question
I don't know still gotta wait the funny
thing is I've been trying to be a good
teammate this whole time and like I feel
like it's gotten me killed like multiple
times
awkward silence yeah let's do it alright
let's try this one last time um favorite
gun probably r01 or Spitfire personally
you can change the way damaged art looks
yeah
okay see even the other guy was like hey
why aren't you drop it
I feel like this new legend is useless I
don't think so I think I think there's
gonna be useless for you think that
I think that they've just got to be
discovered my favorite gun hey this guy
in CR 99 okay so he was talking to our
99 last time he said she's fast like him
yeah down to enemy or ta can use your
dumb pad oh that's cool
it's all gonna do did all useless
useless junk there on this ship let's go
party at the ship the party's at the
ship supply ship over there no no party
how's that guy not picked up armor
redline being a bad teammate shields
here level one
thanks Ricky Martinez 4:7 appreciate
Ethan are you do you realize the person
that the people that made this game is
the people that made time fall so I
would think that it would resemble that
to some degree this dream needs to end
[Applause]
there's people everywhere
an alternator
this is crazy like none of its eluted
there's nothing but hostiles over there
Kobe
I'm ready to watch me die horrible that
so close all right I can't do it anymore
I would like to see it Rico
I honestly would like to see it I feel
like anyone that comes in to tell you
like your game play is not that good
like clearly doesn't have much to do in
their day so so I find it kind of
hilarious but you know that's fine it is
what it is it's all good anyways thank
you all for tuning in appreciate it that
was some octane gameplay not the best
octane gameplay obviously but it's
pretty cool I think that it's gonna be
interesting to see all the stuff that
people do with them
as it stands I feel like you know
Bangalore's passive is you know pretty
much the same thing except you know you
get to stim pack yourself and I don't
know jump pad might have applications
you can apparently jump at a mirage
decoy you can apparently jump pad down
just a teammate which is pretty good too
yeah so I don't know check them out if
you want to 12,000 credits or 950 coins
I think and then if you want battle pass
that's also out that's 950 coins trying
to think that's it if you get to 100 the
the battle pass has like a havoc that
apparently like evolves through the game
thanks guys I know you do
you need to rush people more I'm trying
but then see it's like twofold Abraham
you rush the team and you're you're
pinging it and you're telling your
teammates hey I'm gonna go in after this
and then your teammates are either like
super far behind or aren't there and
then it's like everyone tells you why
didn't you wait for your teammates and
why didn't you fight with your teammates
so there's not really like a really good
back and forth there I will be back
tomorrow for another screen but for
something else different game we have
something a couple days early so you can
you know check that out if you want to
and yeah come back at 11 because that's
when you highlight of us until next time
become champions y'all cuz I couldn't do
it today but I hope you guys are and you
guys are having fun time with the either
bow pass or octane if you don't have
them yet just keep playing you'll get to
it it's a fun game regardless peace out